the lexus NX in the luxury line variant
the first compact SUV that lexus brought
onto the market was a hybrid the NX 300h
now the Japanese company has introduced
a version with only a gasoline engine
the NX 200t
with annoying and Expo test driver
Robert sighting says lexus is the
world's last premium manufacturer to
build a compact SUV but the NX is tough
competition for the others protruding
wheel arches and crisp edges make it
stand out from the crowd that's cuff
full of this the leonine design and a
radiator grille that seems to roar might
lead you to think that the NX turns out
a lot of co2 but the NX first came out
as a hybrid and so even the low version
with the gasoline-powered 2-liter
four-cylinder turbo engine is based on a
low emission fuel-saving concept these
extra tautological a six-speed automatic
transmission calculates the right torque
for each driving situation so the
accelerator pedal responds more
spontaneously and the NX consumes less
fuel the aggressive design language and
the highly reflective titanium silver
color make the annex a choice for
extroverted drivers who want to be
noticed
the turbocharged 4-cylinder engine
produces a hefty 175 kilowatts that an
all-wheel drive with the lexus launched
from 0 to 100 km/h and 7.1 seconds
selling for 50 8250 euros in germany our
test car is in the same price range as
they similarly equipped out eq5
lexis present yet Robert says the
ambience and outfitting of the NX are
genteel with no expense spared head up
head up display touchpad 360-degree
camera surveillance and an adaptive
speed control that keeps the car a
constant distance from the vehicle in
front and that in combination with the
pre-crash safety system can bring the
car to a full stop all on its own mr.
stuck-up cleansed the interior displays
typical Lexus elegance the highlight of
the luxury line is bamboo trimming along
with plenty of digital technology
there's still room for an analog clock
the driver can choose among three
driving modes with a switch the
navigation system is operated with a
touchpad
the angle of the rear seat backrest can
be varied as desired electronically the
hatch opens electronically as well to
reveal 580 liters of storage space and a
large compartment under the cargo floor
the Lexus and your test driver is
impressed with the NX 200t powerful
acceleration and torque Lexus sells a
lot in the United States so suspension
comfort is written large in this SUV but
it offers more feel for the road than
the soft riverboat atmosphere of an
American car its agility makes it
well-suited to European metropolis for
people who don't want a hybrid the NX
200t is a good alternative luxury line
version costs 50 8250 euros and up in
Germany and is available with all-wheel
drive there is a basic version with
front-wheel drive for fifteen thousand
euros less the price for the lexus is
comparable to that of its competitors
and similar versions the lexus NX 200t s
unique design is probably its primary
unique selling point